models
thanks lisa it's my great honor to be
here to present uh our recent work with
peter
and
my first encounter with peter was at
beijing
back then i was still undergrads in
peking university and i was working on
some econometrics problems that has
something to do with nonparametrics and
uh we'll use some techniques like strong
embeddings so i got a chance to read
some of peter's very old papers in the
60s and 70s i don't know if you still
remember that
but then one day i received a talk
announcement saying peter bickle will
come to picken university to give a talk
and i was so shocked and i just went to
the talk and turns out it's not just one
talking picking university and there are
also two other talks in singapore
university so i basically i attended all
of them so i just
follow him and
it was so nice that peter even set up
one hour to chat with me and brought up
some very important references turns out
to be crucial in my undergrad thesis
and so then i began to wonder that's
before my phd application so i wonder if
i were to get a chance to go to berkeley
to do my phd i would definitely ask
peter to be my advisor if that's
possible so the first day i came to
berkeley came to the allen's hall i just
stopped by peter's office and
i wasn't that straightforward but
basically i'm saying can you be my
advisor and
peter said yes so then the journey
started
and i'm sure that as with all other
peter students it's so enjoyable to work
with peter on project and making
progress and solve heart problems
but here today i'm not going to
highlight that part
what i want to say is it's also very
exciting when i got stuck in a project
because there you can just come to
peter's office and say let's derail this
conversation let's think about something
else which could be crazy
and here say peter i got this crazy idea
which i found there is an almost five
percent of chance to work out
and instead of saying don't waste your
time on that peter was that tell me
about that and all very often almost
every time peter will give me some
positive feedback
and eventually i think my estimate of
five percent is quite accurate it's very
calibrated in the sense that maybe only
one out of 20 crazy ideas eventually
work out and here's one of them
so this is a very unusual
work which
where we propose some methods but at
this moment at least now
i didn't expect any of you to use that
so i'm not going to give you a cell of
this method
but in the meantime i think i can walk
through every detail in the paper nearly
every detail in the paper in 30 minutes
so you will see how weird at this and
this is perhaps one of the weirdest idea
i've ever had with peter
and as with other um speakers i also
look at
the mass genealogy and i found myself
the 61st students of peter so i'm among
definitely amongst the youngest students
of peter but today i'm going to talk
about one of the oldest problems in
statistics that is how to do hypothesis
testing for linear models and our
setting
is
so simple here you have a linear model
you have y and you have an intercept and
you have a covariate matrix x and some
unknown coefficient beta star and some
random error
and now the goal is to test whether some
linear contrast of beta star equals to
zero
and in particular without loss of
generality you can do some rotation
because this is the first fixed design
matrix so you can do some rotation to
change that hypothesis into something
called a sub hypothesis which is to test
whether the first r entries equal to
zero so maybe the most interesting case
would just be to test
whether the first entry equals to zero
or not
this is of course one of the most asian
problems and it starts from this guy so
anyone has a guide of who does this
yes this is william gossett
also known as student
so in 1908
he wrote two papers which basically
established the foundation of the t-test
the first one is on one-sided sorry one
sample t-test and the second one is on
two-sided
two-sample t-test
so
turns out there's a special case of the
linear model where the first one can be
viewed as testing rather than intercept
equal to zero with no newton's factors
and the second one is a one-dimensional
linear model and you're going to test
whether that coefficient the slope
equals to zero with the intercept being
the usage parameter
and later on
fischer get really excited about this
idea
although
students were didn't pick up much
attention back then i think it's it was
pretty fortunate owen fisher
didn't notice that work and then he
pushed that forward
so in 20 in 1922 and 1925
he
completely generalized these ideas so
like in the 22 paper he talked about how
to test the global now while treating
the intercept as a nutrients parameter
and then in his elaborated monograph
statistical method for risk workers in
1925
he generalized that
and so now we are going to talk about
this problem
and
because this is a century-long problem
whatever we're going to propose we need
to ask ourselves this question is that
really new
because it's been 100 years
whatever method you are proposing there
might be something
happening in 1960s or 70s or 80s and
there might be a paper there
which has been forgotten in history
and you can't claim that your method is
new so
for that reason
we actually did a literature review from
1908 to 2018.
and we call it a selective review of the
century-long effort and this is appendix
v of our paper
and this
review includes about 250 references but
i don't think it's exhaustive so it
definitely i'm definitely missing a lot
of important ones
but i the reason i call it selective is
that
in this review we only focus on the most
generic problem so there's no high
dimensions there's no sparsity there's
no bayesian things there's no breakdown
points
just on this pure problem
we review like 250 papers and roughly
speaking we can categorize the existing
tasks into those classes where the
regression rml estimate base test and
actually peter is the pioneer of the our
estimate
test and then bootstrap test and some
non-certain non-standard tasks
and i think what's fascinating about
this is that now i got a chance to look
at the history and to see what happens
and there are some surprising things so
for example i thought the ram test was
way later but it can actually date back
to uh
milton friedman in 1937 and also for
symmetry based tests there have been
some works by henry theo the inventor of
two six least squares and many other
things in 1950 so you can see you can
really get back to very early history of
statistics to get some of those
and many of these methods
are working very well that they're shown
to be very robust in many settings
so that's why we're not going to propose
a superior methods that dominate this
method but we're going to ask this
question
when are these tests exact or valid in
financing
so suppose i'm someone who don't like
asymptotics we just have this funny
example and we want our typo error to be
exactly controlled then what conditions
do they need
turns out this is a little bit
frustrating
so what we can
in our review we found that for example
the t and f tests are exact with
gaussian errors and i talked with steve
stickler on this and he pointed out that
actually fischer never required
gaussianity
because all of his proofs are purely
geometric so um
the underlying example should be
rotation variance but an old result from
maxwell in 1860 shows that if you have
rotation variance and independence then
it must be gaussian
so that means rotation variance is a
strong assumption
and the permutation tests are very
robust but in theory they're only exact
for global now or certain anova problems
and rent-based tasks and also the
test-based zone regression r and l
estimate can also be made exact for
global now
there are some non-standard tests like
heart against typical values which i
found very interesting but i don't think
many people know about this
and that can be made exact for some
balanced anova problem with symmetric
errors
and finally there's a recent work by
michelson in 2015
which is exactly rotationally invariant
errors with no noise level
so you can see all these assumptions are
very strong
another question is can we derive the
exact task for sub hypothesis
so there's a very simple strategy which
is you can look at the global now and
you can use any exact test and invert it
so that will give you a joint confidence
region for every parameter including all
the news inspector and then you look at
projection
but that's going to be very conservative
because you are not focusing your power
on the parameter of interest
and often it's computationally
infeasible even with the moderate like
10.
but the question is why are these exact
tests for sub-hypothesis so hard to come
by
i think there are two of them
one is most exact word one of them most
exact tests are exploiting some grouping
variants like permutation tests or
randomization inference
but often they assume that there's no
news inspector or under the now you have
a simple after conditioning all
this randomization
but when you have nuisance parameter
like the other coefficient it's very
hard to maintain the good grouping
variance
well on the other hand why are exact
tests so important i think first many
tasks would require essentially required
that you can consistently estimate all
the nuisance parameters
but that's hard like for me
one
big thing in my research agenda is how
can you get valid tests without
consistently estimating the entire
system
so we want that and the second thing is
it's simply an intellectual challenge
because no test exact under reasonable
general assumptions over the past 110
years
so in this talk we will introduce a test
called cyclic permutation test which is
valid in finance samples for arbitrary
fixed design matrix x and arbitrary
exchangeable errors epsilon so you don't
need moments you don't need assumptions
on x and of course if x is too bad then
you wouldn't have power
but this will achieve exact type of
error if one over alpha is an integer
and further it will be non-randomized if
the ratio between the sample size and
number of nuisance parameters is greater
than one over alpha
and moreover through simulation we can
show that it will achieve a reasonable
power if this ratio is much larger than
one or alpha like 1.5 or off
so for example if you want to test
whether the first entry equals to zero
with alpha equal to 0.05 you just need n
over p to be bigger than 20 for validity
and 30 for reasonable power
so what's the idea
so the idea is that let's construct a
pool of statistics which are linear
combinations of y so here y is a
n-dimensional vector
and we're going to construct some linear
combinations
and our goal is to say if this set of
statistics has some properties which are
introduced in the next slide we will
calculate the rank of the first one and
we hope that this rank is uniform under
the now but extreme under the
alternative
then we will reject each now if this
rank is extreme
so in particular of course we would
think about exchangeability but in order
for this test to work we don't need
exchangeability we just need a cyclic
permutation group
so here we will call this set of
statistic invariant under cyclic
permutation group if the distribution
doesn't change if you move the elements
one element to the right
so
in other words this group only has n
plus one element it doesn't have m plus
one factorial elements
this is almost a trivial result that
once you have this property then if you
do any transformation of the scores and
you
calculate the rank of the first one then
that rank will be uniform if there's no
pi
and as a result if you normalize that
rank by n plus 1 it will be a valid
p-value
and moreover if r equal to some
multiples of 1 over
m plus 1 then this will be
exact okay
now the question is how do you construct
these coefficient factors
so recall that we have two goals one is
we want validity meaning that this set
of statistics should be invariant under
this group under the now but in the
meantime we want high power meaning that
under the alternative the first one will
be larger
so let's talk about validity first
so first we partition x into two parts
one corresponding to the first r columns
the other corresponding to the rest
and then y can be written that way
and then any linear combination of y can
be written in the following so there are
three terms and then algebra now the
first term goes away so we are left with
two terms
the first term is deterministic
and the second term is red
so the idea is quite simple is that what
if we can match the deterministic part
and make the stochastic part invariant
under the cyclic permutation group if we
can achieve that then we're done
okay so let's look at how to achieve
that so the first one is
the simplest way to match the
deterministic part is to make that
coefficient the a transpose x minus r to
be the same
for every linear combination
so let's call this common value gamma
minus r
so the first set of condition for this
atas is that they should satisfy the
first boiling point
okay that's a set of linear equations
and then we need to think about how to
make the stochastic part in vary that's
perhaps the most important part in this
talk
so turns out
the intuition is quite simple if all
these vectors are shifted version of the
other
then this set of linear combinations
should also be invariant under the
cyclic permutation group
and for simplicity let me give you an
example with six samples and m equals to
two so that we are going to construct
three statistics
and in this case
six divided by three equals two so we
will last eight a zero to be
eight one star to add a six star and
then we would like eta one to be eight
three four five six one two and eta two
to be 5 6 1 2 3 4.
so every time you just move two elements
to the left
if this holds then we show that the
stochastic part will be invariant
let me explain why this is true
so this is a special case where let's
rewrite these three statistics so we
know that
this
statistics would be equal to this matrix
of adas multiplied by the error term
but of course we can exchange eta and
epsilon so we get a matrix of epsilon
multiplied by a vector of eta
and then if we shift one statistic to
the left we will get the same thing so
again we will get the matrix of epsilon
multiplied by a vector of eta
and then if epsilon exchangeable
these two matrices of epsilon will have
the same distribution because they're
shifting the rows
and as a consequence these two
random vectors would have the same
distribution so you can apply the same
logic to get this in variance
but then you may ask
is this sickly permutation group or an
artifact or do we actually have
exchangeability so if we have that
then we don't need to talk about this
but actually we don't
so let's look at another
permutation of the three statistics
where you just exchange the last two so
this is not a cyclic permutation
then you can
rewrite this as a matrix of epsilon
multiplied by eta and you can find these
three elements so you see in the left
those three elements are equal almost
surely but in the right they are not
so in general without further
assumptions these two vectors do not
have the same distribution so in other
words
under this construction they're only
invariant with respect to the cyclic
permutation group
instead of the exchangeable group
so now let's get back to this
so in order to match the deterministic
part we have the set of linear equations
and in order to make the stochastic part
in variance we need a j to be shifted
version of one
vector
and turns out the second one is also a
linear equation
because you can imagine that this left
shifting operator is the linear operator
so you can just define this capital pi
as the permutation matrix corresponding
to that left shifting
and you can rewrite the set of
conditions as a linear system
so the whole thing in order to get a
valid test you just need to solve a
linear system now let's get back to our
linear algebra 101 when does a linear
system has a solution
we know that that would happen as long
as the number of variables is bigger
than the number of equations
now let's do the counting
so here the number of variables is the
dimension of gamma minus r and eta star
so gamma minus r is p minus r the number
of newton's factors and the dimension of
a to star is n so overall you have m
plus r minus
n plus b minus r variables the number of
equations is just the total number of
rows of this matrix that's going to be m
plus one times p minus r
so as a result we only need n to be
bigger than p minus r times m
to get a valid test
here is just a summary again i think
once you figure it out everything here
there's no technical argument it's just
linear algebra 101.
so
assume n is divisible by an n plus one
then this linear system will always have
a
zero solution as long as you have this
ratio bigger than m
and for any solution this will give you
a valid test
that's the first part and the some
general comments
first
we want alpha to be a multiples of one
over n plus 1 in order to get a
non-randomized exact test because here
the p-value only take values as
multiples of 1 over m plus 1.
so in particular if one or alpha is an
integer we can simply set m to be 1 over
r from minus 1. in the case where alpha
equal to 0.05 you can just set them to
be 19.
so in this case we just need the ratio
of n and number of nuisance parameters
to be at least 19.
so this is quite reasonable assumption
at least in social science
and also when r is large like say you
have a lot of fixed effect which are new
using parameters but you want to test
global now then you can do better
okay that's about validity
but valid test is not hard to come by
you can do some arbitrary things by
generating a
random number
random uniform random variable
but here we also need to talk about
power
and for power let's assume we're just
gonna test
one coefficient like beta 1 star equals
to zero
then we will have three parts
and under the previous construction we
have already shown that the second two
parts are invariant
so all the signal part will goes to
the first component which has something
to do with beta 1 star
and to enhance power we simply want the
coefficient in front of beta 1 star to
be much larger for the first statistics
and a very simple setting to make that
happen is you set all the others to be
equal
and set the first one to be that number
plus some delta
and here
if this all this a js the coefficient
vectors have normal one you can view
this delta as a signal to noise ratio
so let's put them together and you can
see here in order to get a good power we
just add a bunch of new linear equations
and again we can rewrite them as a
linear system
and we can apply the same reasoning so
as long as the number of variables is
larger than number of equations we will
have a solution
and in this case the condition would be
l over p bigger than or equal to 19 or m
and then
here because when we have that condition
a linear system has infinite solutions
and because x is deterministic so we are
free to choose anyone we like
and the very natural idea is to just to
find one find the data star vector such
that the signal to noise ratio is
maximized
so let's solve this linear programming
problem where our objective is just to
maximize delta and our constraint is
that giant linear system
it turns out this is very easy to do it
just has something to do with all the
last
you just run all or less of one column
in that coefficient matrix on the others
and that will give the answer so i
wouldn't delve into detail the point of
this
result is just to show that it's very
easy to
get this number
[Music]
so far
we have using some weird techniques to
get this test
but now here comes the weirdest part
so let's review this coefficient matrix
you see that here we have this x
transpose pi
and the pi is say
it's corresponding to the left shifting
operator so in other words
it will let's say m equal to 19. so it
would
divide x into 20 chunks
and every time it will move the chunks
to the left
that means
this test depends on how you arrange the
rows or the observations of x
right this doesn't hold for any other
test because any other test if you do
t-test or f-test or permutation test it
it wouldn't depends on how you rearrange
the rows but this one does
so as a result
delta star the signal to noise ratio
as a function of the permutation of the
rows of x
it
does depends on that permutation
and here's this quick simulation to tell
you how much fluctuation you have
so here i generate three matrices one
from koji one from normal one from t5
and i just generate one copy of that
and then i generate a lot of
permutations of the rows and each time i
calculate this delta star
and here's the histogram so you can see
for the koji case the largest one has
signal to noise ratio six but the
smallest one has that only a half so
that means if you can find a good
pre-ordering of the rows you can have 12
large 12 times larger signal to noise
ratio so that means we have to do
something here
[Music]
so here the ideal thing is let's just
maximize
this signal-to-noise ratio with respect
to all the permutations
and we know that this is a non-linear
traveling salesman problem it's
definitely np hard there's no solution
anyone who had come up with say exact
solution would bring every word in in
the world
but here fortunately we don't need to
exactly solve this
we just need a good value or we just
need a good permutation
so in our work we just apply the genetic
algorithm to find a good permutation
and we implemented that by some r
package
and here's the illustration so i simply
compare this genetic algorithm with the
naive stochastic search by that i mean
you just randomly
choose some permutations and then take
the best
so you can see that
like here in x-axis we give the number
of samples
and in the y-axis i give that delta-star
x sorry that's a typo
and you can see genetic algorithm can
actually improve over time but
stochastic search will quickly get
trapped in a local minimum
that's not surprising because this is a
giant space it's very hard for
a random search to
get to the right point
so just to summarize this test and
that's already the test so first we
apply the genetic algorithm to find this
ordering and then we reorder y and x
reorder the observations
and let's call that y q to x tilde then
we use our method to compute that eta
star by solving that giant linear system
and we compute this score
which is
the linear combination of this y tilde
and in the previous slides i only talked
about one-sided test so you can directly
calculate the rank of the first one but
also works for two-sided path because
you can do any transformation of those
scores as long as it is exchangeable
so for example you can subtract the
media of the scores from the first one
and then calculate the rank
and finally you calculate the p-value
and if you don't want randomization you
can simply use r over n plus one
and finally you reject the now if the p
value is below alpha
so that's the test
and once you have the test we can invert
it to get a confidence interval right
because in many cases we don't care
about
the p-value itself we care about the
confidence interval
and
here you can just do the directing
version
so for example here you can try every
value of beta1
or you can try a great grid of value of
beta1 and then every time you subtract
x1 beta1 from y then that will give you
a null case
and you calculate this p bar and you
collect all beta-1 such that this
p-value is above alpha
and this will be a valid confidence
interval in finite samples
and
the rest of the computation is yeah it's
just
illustrating how to how to do this so it
turns out
that
in this case
we can write down the confidence bound
simply as a minimum of things
so it's very easy to compute where the
numerator has to do with those linear
combination of y and the denominator is
the signal to noise ratio
okay
then we have done a lot of simulations
and again as i mentioned in at beginning
we're not proposing some methods
superior to others so it turns out those
permutation tests are pretty robust even
if there's
no theory under very general assumptions
but they're robust so perhaps if we were
to
advertise one methods we should still
advertise those existing permutation
tests but here this is just to show you
what happens with some
with some
types of design matrix and some types of
errors so the first example is we
generate the housing x but then we fix
it to make this a fixed design linear
regression and we generate gaussian
error
and then here we set the sample size to
be a thousand and p to be like 40 33 and
25 so that's the ratio is like 25 30 and
40.
and then we generate
many copies of x and for each copy of x
we generate multiple copies of epsilon
so that for each x we can get this type
of error and then across different
realizations we can get this box plot
to show the variation of the type of
error
and here we consider three versions of
our test
with strong we can random role ordering
by ordering i mean so here strong means
we apply genetic algorithm with many
many samples and by weak
we just mean that we apply genetic
algorithm with a few samples and the
random ordering is just take a random
permutation
and then here as a comparison we also
include
the friedman lane test which is the
residual permutation test and also the
test based on the least absolute
deviation regression
but here the disclaimer is that we're
just using the asymptotic-based test for
our id we're not using bootstrap because
bootstrap is more robust
but you can see even with a thousand
samples and
just
like one or two dozens of variables the
outdated
the lad will have an inflated type one
error
so that means that the asymptotic
doesn't really kick in in this case but
for all the other tests they're pretty
much
retaining the type of error
and this is about power so here in order
to study power we need to give beta a
particular value
and here i just tune the beta 1 such
that the t test has 20 power as a
benchmark
and then we compare
we compute the ratio between our test
and the task to be compared
so you can see that when orp is like 25
which is slightly larger than 20
our test does have a lower power
but as things goes to 40 and as the
signal strength goes larger then our
test it's reasonable i wouldn't say it's
very powerful but it's reasonable
and the next case is code gx plus code
error everything else is the same and in
this case we know that t test is not
good but it's not good in the
conservative way
so actually i have spent a lot of time
trying to
get a case where t-test violates the
type one error but i can never get it
maybe you can get like point five
percent of violation but i can never get
that so if anyone has some experience
with t-tests then please let me know
and for lad on average will give you the
right top point error but it has large
fluctuation
and for the power you can see our test
is marginally more powerful than the
t-test but compared to the frequent lane
test and lad still less powerful
so
in the last two minutes i'm gonna make
uh just a few quick comments the first
one is is this n over p bigger than one
alpha essential
so at first glance it might seems to be
essential because like it basically says
that for every covariate you have at
least one or r for samples
but turns out it's not
i mean if this were to be essential that
means if we want to test this hypothesis
a level 0.05 which was suggested
recently by asa then we would need an
overp to be greater than
199 and that's almost never the case
but turns out we just need ltp to be
bigger than eight
for alpha equal to 0.05 and 14 for 0.005
and i'm not going to delve into this
this is even crazier and we're not sure
if this has high power
so the trade-off between the type 1
error and type 2 errors is very unclear
and this is an ongoing project with
peter but i put a question mark there
because i really don't know if we are
going to pursue that
[Music]
and here are some open questions like
first
can we do some approximate cpd so here
we just use the exact cpd
and we want that
invariance to be exact but what if we
allow us to be approximately satisfying
that's invariant to the cyclic
permutation group then maybe we can
relax the orp ratio condition a lot
and also this test doesn't work for
heteroskedastic linear models and how to
deal with that or how to deal with the
structural error distribution that's
another question
and finally it seems like this test is
hinging on the linear model
and it's unclear whether we can
generalize that to general generalized
linear model or other on nonlinear
models
so just to wrap up in this talk we
propose the sickly permutation test
which is valid in finite examples for
arbitrary fixed design matrix and
arbitrary exchangeable errors
and it has exact type of error if one or
alpha is an integer and it's now
randomized if the ratio between the
sample size and the number of newton's
parameters is greater than one over
alpha
and through simulation we show it has
reasonable power if that ratio is much
bigger than one over alpha
so the main message will convey here is
how to partial
newton's parameters while maintaining
grouping variants because i think
nuisance parameters and grouping
variants are two big topics in
statistics
and when they meet each other can we
really deal with them
that's the general question i want to
ask instead of just proposing a method
and
lastly i want to encourage you to check
out our literature review because many
of you are much more knowledgeable
knowledgeable about the history than me
and i really want some help
on whether i'm missing some really
really important work and with that i'd
like to thank you all for your attention
and happy birthday peter
to learn the long history so how many
different tests have been proposed in
that long list 20 30 50
i think more than that
so suppose you to take a random data set
from ucry
what do you think the conclusion will be
different based on these different tests
i think
for those permutations this is my
general observation for this permutation
test like frequently it's going to be
like the best it's very robust in
almost every data set and i couldn't
find a case that this is not good but
then for some other tasks my question
was really um like how many of them
going to make a different decision right
right most of them are similar i would
say yeah so for from practitioner point
of view
how can help them choose that's why
people do t tests right is that uh
do we want to need more tests
yeah that's a great question i think
maybe we don't right so we know that t
t-test itself is
not that robust but permutation t-test
is very robust so maybe that's the only
thing we need
yeah
so here the whole point is it's just to
say
say like yeah it's it's this one i'm
making so like i don't know i don't
think this test is going to be useful
but
it's really about idea about how to
combine newton's parameters with
grouping variance
thanks for the presentation um my
my question is really about the
clarification i i i may have missed some
some part of your procedure but
you showed that type 1 error is is
is is guaranteed when you set delta to
be zero
but but but do you always optimize to
find that delta
or like
like if you happened like under the
let's say now model and you happen to
optimize for for that delta and you use
the non-zero delta it is type one error
still guaranteed yes yes so here delta
is
it's just a coefficient
for um for the signal to noise ratio so
here delta will give you a difference
between the first one and the rest of
them
after multiplying by beta y star so if
beta 1 star is actually 0
then this delta doesn't matter because
they're still the same
so so i would say this delta times beta
1 star is the is the signal
it's the signal stress
okay so this will still maintain the
type one error because as long as you
have those uh constructions then you
will be guaranteed to have them okay
yeah no i see it thank you thank you
uh i have a question on the
computational aspect if if m is small
you can just do both false over all
possible permutations right
so what if
can you do like a divide and conquer if
n is large split it into two subparts
you know do permutations on one and on
the other and
understand which combinations will give
you a large delta without
yeah yeah but here you see that that's a
great question but here this is a
permutation on n samples so if n is
small like 20 then you can do that but
typically the sample size is not that
small so you should still apply some
algorithm it doesn't have to be genetic
algorithm so for example you can imagine
that this is a combinatorial
optimization problem and you can
think about some convex relaxation we
actually discussed that in the paper and
maybe you can use that to find a good
approximation very quickly
but i think the exhaustive search is not
realistic in typical problems
all right um i think we can take
remaining questions offline um
before we
yes peter
i'd like to make it clear that although
i asked some questions which were
relevant his very clever ideas really
essentially
was
the other thing is that there is
um
well this project that
might take place would it be looking at
other subgroups in the cyclic group
right where you could maybe get
better control of the type one error
and possibly larger power however i
think the real question is not so much
with this particular test
but the the interesting question is when
can you use
subgroups of the permutation group
in in a useful way to
enable
distribution pre-testing
thanks peter
[Music]
so just um one quick announcement before
you disperse for lunch ashley um the
simon stuff is waiting outside to take a
group picture so we'll just do just
outside when everybody comes out right
katrina that way in the back where the
coffee was
and then we come back at 1 40 for the
last session let's thank both our
speakers again
[Applause]
so